let's try using this concept of function to look at a graph. Remember at the
beginning, I said that linear equations always represent functions, we know this
because the input always produces exactly one output and we actually have a way
of testing it. We can use a vertical line test to determine if a graph
represents a set of points that is a function. If a vertical line only crosses
the graph once then the graph represents a function. Just like in this case we
know every x value on this graph has exactly one corresponding Y value. We know
every input on this graph has exactly one corresponding output, or y value. So
in this case we know the graph and its linear equation represent a function.
Here's a completely different equation that you've never seen before. And this
is its graph. If we use the vertical line test on this function. We can see that
it hits the function once here, and then the vertical line crosses twice at two
different places. This happens for many points along the graph. So we know this
graph and this equation do not represent a function. Let's move over a quill
line a little bit back and look at it when x equals 4. So here's our vertical
line x equals 4 and I can see that I have two points on my graph. I have the
point 4, 2 and 4, negative 2. Notice that the same input x equals 4 produces two
different outputs, positive 2 or negative 2. Again this is why the graph is not
a function.